تحلق على ارتفاع منخفض فوق الريف الأوكراني
، تتجه هذه الطائرة العسكرية التي تعود إلى الحقبة السوفيتية
نحو الحدود مع
روسيا ،
سافرنا هنا مع كبار
المسؤولين الأوكرانيين والقادة العسكريين للتعرف
على الحالة المزاجية والاستعدادات حيث
تكون القوات الروسية هي الأقرب بالقرب
من منطقة دونباس الشرقية في أوكرانيا.
avdivka حيث كان العديد من هذه
القوات الأوكرانية ، ومعظمهم من
الشباب ، يقاتلون القوات المدعومة من روسيا
في هذا الهدف الأمامي البارد المقفر ،
فهم حريصون على أن يوضحوا لنا كيف
كانوا يعيشون ويقاتلون هنا في
صراع تشارك فيه روسيا.
منسي إلى حد كبير ولكنه
أودى بحياة أكثر من 14 ألف شخص في السنوات
الثماني الماضية وفقًا للأمم المتحدة ،
لقد كان إيفان هنا طوال الوقت مثل
الجنود الآخرين هنا ، وهو يقول إنهم
واثقون من أنهم قد يواجهون غزوًا روسيًا
جديدًا بالطبع نحن  مستعد لبعض
المواقف السيئة ونحن ننتظر هنا بشكل أساسي ،
هل تعتقد أن هذا سيحدث هذا
الوضع السيئ أه أنا لست كذلك
ولكني لا أعرف لأنني لا  لا أعرف
ما في رأس
الرجال في تلك المنطقة ، لكن بالنسبة لك ،
بدأت الحرب بالفعل ، بالطبع ، تم
نقلنا إلى أبعد نقطة
للأمام حيث تتراكم أكياس الرمل والإطارات
عالياً ،
لذلك كان هناك انفجار مما
بدا وكأنه  إطلاق نار آلي
على بعد 70 مترًا فقط
قيل لنا من المقاتلين على
الجانب الآخر من خط المواجهة أننا
هرعنا بعيدًا بفريق المرافقين لدينا
لنرى ما سيحدث ولكن لا نسمع عن كثب
هذا إطلاق النار وأن نكون قريبين جدًا من
هذا الخط الأمامي  لا يسعك إلا
أن تعتقد أنه حتى لو نجحت الدبلوماسية في
منع روسيا من غزو أوكرانيا
مرة أخرى ، فإن هذا القتال الذي كان
محتدماً منذ آخر مرة
غزت فيها روسيا أوكرانيا ، يكاد يكون من المؤكد أن
قادة الناتو يقولون إن إنهاء
القتال الدائر بالفعل هنا أمر
بالغ الأهمية.  جزء من منع المزيد من
العدوان الروسي
مع رفض الناتو حتى الآن إرسال قوات
إلى أوكرانيا لمحاربة أوكرانيا يصر على أنها
بحاجة إلى مزيد من المساعدة ولكن القضية المهمة
ما يحتاجون إليه هو
مساعدة أسلحة إضافية من الغرب من
حلفائنا الغربيين في نهاية المطاف
مساعدة مالية هذا ما نحتاجه
للتأكد من أننا سندافع ليس فقط عن السلام
في هذا البلد ولكن عن السلام في أوروبا
المزيد من إطلاق النار